let's go next to our caller from the seven
one seven area code.
Who's calling today from seven one seven.
Hello, David.
My name is Lucas.
Uh, I'm a college student here in Pennsylvania.
And I was curious, uh, your reaction to Pete
Buddhist says taking the earliest lead was
62% of the result, um, giving in Iowa and
if you had any thoughts on his progress and
he, when he was doing his speech to the news,
he kept emphasizing how his team of four people
came from nowhere and people said he wouldn't
be able to do his thing because he was just
a mayor.
And how you feel that to fund his progress
so far?
Oh, well even with now, you know, we're, we're
beyond 62% P boot edge edge still is doing
very well.
I don't think that much of it in terms of
like, I don't find his campaign very interesting.
He's much too centrist for my taste.
I, I'm interested in the strategy for the
DNC establishment because Pete booed edge
edge did well in Iowa and Joe Biden did not
do well despite what the polls said going
in.
I'm curious to see whether the establishment
shifts that support away from Biden and to
Pete or potentially even to Michael Bloomberg
because Bloomberg has almost unlimited spending
capacity and now potentially will be participating
in upcoming debates because of the rule changes.
So my view on Pete, you know, I think his,
his view on healthcare is wacky and w you
know, I think his background as, as a consultant
does not make him, uh, uniquely well-suited
to be president.
And you know, claiming victory before any
votes were counted was really weird.
What are, you know, none of that my view on
none of that has changed.
Uh, but I'm interested to see whether the
DNC gets behind him and abandons Biden.
Right.
And one more thing, uh, I found something
interesting on you could visit and watch.
There was such a divide between age ranges
and who they supported.
Um, I believe it said that people over 65
were hardcore supporting, um, Joe and then
people around my age and the twenties were
more so supporting Bernie.
And if you have any advice or anything, how
did people in their twenties actually get
out to the polls?
Because I know we need
turn out to actually make a difference in
defeat Trump.
Yeah, I don't have the silver bullet every
election.
It's always this discussion is, Hey, you know
what X candidate is doing so well among young
voters, but young voters are far less likely
to actually go out and vote.
How do we mobilize them?
And if, if I had figured that out, I'd probably
be a political consultant at this point because
that's a tough nut to crack.
So I don't, I don't have any particular insight.
I really appreciate the phone call Lucas and
I hope to hear from you again.